>>Xavier Ducrohet: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to I/O and welcome our session on
What's New in Android Developer Tools.
My name is Xavier Ducrohet.
>>> I think we have a few things to show.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Maybe.
So Android Studio.
So when we released the first SDK in 2007,
we released some tools with it and since then
we've done a lot of progress in and outside
of the IDE based on Eclipse and we are going
to keep on doing that, but one thing that
we could never really do is really improve
the whole workflow of being an Android developer
inside the IDE, and we really wanted to improve
that.
So when we wanted to concentrate on Android-focused
IDE, we decided to go with IntelliJ.
IntelliJ is a great Java IDE, but it's also
based on a very extensible platform.
It's the same platform that borrowed some
of the other IDE from JetBrains, like (indiscernible),
Python IDE or Javascript IDE.
And the extensibility is really available
throughout.
Some of the core components like product support,
build support, the support that powers all
of the refactoring, all the way up to the
UI where everything is customizable.
>>Tor Norbye: And the build support, that
extensibility is the most important part given
what we're going to show you.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: So this is going to allow
us to create a lot of very advanced features
that we couldn't really do before, but also
creates an experience that is really focused
for Android.
And when we did something in the IntelliJ
platform that is not extensible we worked
directly with JetBrains to make sure that
Web extension point so we don't fog that platform.
We're just basing all IDE on their platform.
We're using everything that they're doing.
In fact, we're actually building on top of
their existing Android support.
So it had support for building, editing, debugging
and not just extending that.
So in the past few months we've mostly worked
in our internal repository because we wanted
that to be a surprise, and today we're moving
back to the open source project, so it's live
now in AOSP and since we're doing that we
figured out we would also give you a preview.
So today it went live, not too long ago.
You can go download Android Studio, it's version
0.1.
It's a bit rough around the edges.
The IntelliJ part is mostly stable.
>>Tor Norbye: There are some parts that are
rock solid and other parts that are not.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yes, but we want to have
a lot of feedback.
We want to make the best IDE possible.
We're going to integrate very quickly, fix
bugs, add new features and gather feedback
from you.
So please try it and send us feedback.
Now, I realize that probably some of you,
you know, have never tried IntelliJ before
and so we wanted to give you a quick overview
of IntelliJ before we show you some of the
Android Studio specific features.
So I'm very happy to introduce on stage Dmitry
Jemerov, the CTO of JetBrains to give you
an overview of IntelliJ.
>>> Hello, everyone.
So my name is Dmitry, the CTO of JetBrains.
I'm very excited to be here and thanks for
the warm reception during the keynote.
And I'd like to tell a bit about our side
of this story.
So we have been long watching the work that
the tools team has been doing on the Android
tooling and we have been very impressed with
the quality of that work so we are sure that
our Android plug-in is in good hands now.
From our side we fully support that effort.
We provide the necessary extensions in the
platform that the guys here need from us and
so it's all versed together very nicely.
From our side we're also going to ship all
of that stuff as part of our release as part
of IntelliJ Idea itself.
And for those of you not familiar with our
products, we have actually two editions of
the product.
The IntelliJ IDEA Community edition is the
free and open source version which is what
Android Studio is based on.
And we have IntelliJ IDEA Ultimate, the commercial
edition of the IDE, which also includes support
for server side development, starting with
CSS and JavaScript and proceeding to the Java
enterprise frameworks like Spring Hibernate,
Java EE and stuff like that, database support
and so on.
So if you're working on a pure Android project,
the Android Studio is the best tool of choice
for you and if you have a project that has
a service side component or simply if you're
working in a more distributed environment,
then you might want to look at IntelliJ IDEA
Ultimate.
So now I'm going to give a quick demo of the
features in IntelliJ.
It's not going to be Android specific so that
will be Tor's part of the demo.
I'll just start with a general overview.
So the motto of our company is "Develop with
Pleasure."
And one of the key things from which pleasure
comes during development is not having to
worry about routine tasks, so stuff happening
-- as much stuff as possible should happen
automatically, should be done automatically
for you.
So for example, like routine stuff like saving
files or managing imports, this is all done
for you by the IDE automatically on the fly.
Another part is that IntelliJ IDEA has a wide
array of refactorings and quick fixes for
the problems that you can encounter in your
code.
And we do not see them just as tools for fixing
errors or fixing code that is broken.
We see them as an integral part of the code-writing
experience inside IntelliJ.
And I'm going to show a little bit of how
this works in practice.
So I'm going to start writing -- this is a
simple Android app, a little more than Hello
world.
And I've written a method and told that does
not exist and so now I'll use a quick fix
to create it for me.
Now I'm going to call the regular find ULD
method which all of you know, and now I'll
use refactoring to save this as enter variable.
So I introduce the variable refactoring and
I enter the name of the variable.
And by the way, notice this all happens in
place.
There are no dialogue box popping up, nothing
like that.
Now it has the wrong type and it's actually
a text use so I'm entering text use here.
Of course it can also insert the necessary
type cast for me.
Now I'm going to write some control structures,
2013, and now this statement is incomplete.
It lacks parenthesis and stuff, and I'm going
to use an action called complete statement
that is going to turn this into a complete
statement for me essentially.
So I'm invoking from the menu, but -- you
always use the keyboard for this, but in order
for you to see what I'm doing, the menu is
more clear.
So now this is an unresolved parameter and
I'm going to create this now, create parameter,
and this actually triggers another refactoring,
the change signature refactoring.
And this is going to go through all of the
calls of the method from -- of which there
is only one and it will actually introduce
the necessary value into the call.
Now, set text, Hello I/O.
Of course, this is an Android app so this
is supposed to be a resource and we have a
fix for that, but that's part of Tor's demo,
not mine.
Another thing showing is in IntelliJ IDEA
we have two code completion actions.
There's the regular code completion which
you have seen a number of times already and
we also have the smart app completion.
And the smart app completion actually restricts
the options on the completion list to the
values of the correct type.
And it's actually not something that you always
want, but when you do want it, it's very easy
and accessible using keyboard shortcut.
And if you press the same keyboard shortcut
again it will have return values of the same
type.
Now, actually, it looks like I'm -- I'm not
really going to need this so I'm going to
use another nice coding assistance action
called unwrap remove to get rid of this statement
for me.
I select the option to unwrap gift and, poof,
it disappears.
Now this parent is no longer used and, of
course, there's another quick fix to get rid
of it.
And remove parameter.
It's gone.
By the way, I mentioned background code analysis
and I would like specifically to highlight
some of the (Indiscernible) features.
Some of them are pretty smart.
For example, this is my favorite, inspection.
So when you are writing UI code you can often
make the error of mixing up the coordinates,
mixing up X and Y or height and width or something
like that, and we have built in something
especially for that.
In this case I'm having the max width value
and set the height.
IntelliJ IDEA highlights that problem and
I'm probably doing something wrong and probably
I have messed things up and I should correct
them.
The next thing I would -- I want to look at
is our version control integration.
An important thing to note that in IntelliJ
IDEA all the version control plug-ins such
as gifts (indiscernible) and a few more, they're
all bundled in the distribution of the product
so you don't have to hunt for plug-ins.
All the plug-ins have a consistent user experience
and work in a similar way.
And the key part of the version control integration
is our changes view.
This is the view that shows the list of all
the things that you have modified or added
to the project or removed from the version
control, and it's automatically updated on
the fly.
And you can always access the diffs and see
what changes exactly have you made.
You can also use this view to trigger the
commit action so you select the files that
you want to go in and you click on commit
changes and you get this commit dialogue.
And because this product is using get, I also
get the option to put the changes in -- no,
no, I don't want to do that.
I get the option of push the changes to the
server immediately.
Now, if you want to look at what other people
in the project have been doing, you can use
the get log view for that.
So if you switch to that tab it shows a nice
graph for commit so this part does not have
any complications in branch structure, but
if it had it would be displayed right here.
Of course I can also show diffs to see exactly
was changed and you can pull the latest changes
to my machine.
And another nice thing we have for get is
this branch chooser pop-up.
So right now I am under my diff branch and
I can use a new one that I'm doing or merge
this into the master branch or something like
that.
Now, of course, I could be talking for hours
about different features of the IDE, but we
don't have that much time, so I'll switch
to giving you some useful pointers on how
to explore the IDE further.
So first of all we have this tip of the day
thing.
And unlike some other products it actually
contains useful and relevant information so
you can go look through those and learn something
useful.
Another useful thing is the find action keyboard
shortcut.
So for example, some of the things that I
have used you can type in complete and it
will show the complete commit statement and
shortcut for it so that you can invoke it
that way and learn the keyboard shortcut in
the future.
We also have a blog with a lot of useful information
on our product.
You can follow us on Twitter.
And finally, we have a booth in the developer
sandbox and we will be there for the whole
three days of the conference and if you have
any questions on what's going on with IntelliJ
or how is it better than Eclipse or stuff
like that, please go there and ask us and
we will be happy to answer it -- answer those
questions.
Now I'm handing over to Xav for the communication
demo.
[ Applause ]
>>Xavier Ducrochet: Thank you.
We're really excited to build Studio on IntelliJ.
It's really a fantastic tool.
Now I want to talk a little about project
support because this is something we really
want to do well.
If you look at the current situation you will
-- in Eclipse we have some custom builders.
We have an end script somewhere.
IntelliJ has its own builder and they may
not all do the same thing and it's really
a problem and we wanted to fix that.
We want to have a single system, a system
that's flexible and customizable so that it
can adopt to all your needs, and some of you
have some very specific needs.
And we want to make sure also that whether
you're working in the IDE or whether you're
building in your continuous integration server
then you should have exactly the same results.
If you have some customization and you're
working in the IDE and you don't get the same
result because the IDE doesn't understand
the customization, that's a problem.
So for a little under a year now we've we
started working on that, we started an implementing
a new design build system.
It's based on Gradle and it's very extensive,
customizable and very extensible and it is
deeply integrated into the IDE.
That means that in Studio the different behavior
is when you create a new project it will create
a Gradle project using our Gradle plug-in
and then it will get imported into Studio
using the great Gradle support that JetBrains
is adding into IntelliJ.
And when you're building from studio it's
going to actually delegate the build to Gradle
and have Gradle do the build so that whether
you're inside your IDE or on a build server,
the same result every time, and that's really
important.
We have a concept of a build variant in this
build system.
There was a talk during the keynote talking
about beta test and alpha test and being able
to deploy that to users so we have the ability
to have different build environs whether you
want to do release build or maybe a bit hub
build.
We also have support for debug, for instance.
So here we have a build file that has two
product flavors, paid versus free, then it
has a new build type bit hub.
And you could configure it different ways.
I have a new panel here that shows build IM
that shows I am working right now on the paid
debug version.
That means when I click launch it's actually
launching your paid debug version.
If you look at the source folders on the left
here, the blue source folder, Java here and
then it's source main Java and source paid
Java are your main source folders, so in that
paid Java folder it would put code specific
to that version.
The green version says here that your test
code, so the instrumentation test and instrumentation
test paid, that's your test specifically to
test the paid version.
And notice there's a free Java and -- it says
free Java here.
That's not selected because you're not working
on the free version.
So here, based on everything that we say in
the build script the IDE is aware that you
have six different buy-ins and when you switch
to free debug it's going to automatically
switch those here.
So the IDE is really aware of all your configuration.
A lot of this is working now.
There are some things if you deal with buy-ins
-- if you deal with resources and flavor (indiscernible),
we are going to fix that, but the point here
is that everything that you do in the build
script to customize your application will
be understood by the IDE and that's very important.
I'm not going to talk more about the build
session.
I have a session at 9:00 a.m. on Friday only
about the build session and I encourage you
to attend it.
And now Tor is going to talk for us.
>>Tor Norbye: All right.
So I'm going to focus today on -- is my monitor
okay?
I'm going to focus today on the areas where
Android Studio is different than Eclipse because
there are many things that are the same, so
showing that wouldn't -- we're not trying
to prove that we're done because we're not.
There's many areas that are missing.
So if I can bring up the screen, here you
can see the environment.
And one of the, I think, most noticeable features
is when you're editing layouts you get this
preview on the right and we have a little
bit of eye candy.
We've got Romain Guy's device frame art integrated
so you can sort of see the device here.
So if I switch, for example, to Galaxy Nexus
I can see that art and with drop shadows and
everything.
And if you don't like that, if you really
want your pixels back, which I understand,
you can go to the options and turn off the
device frame so you can take all the space
for the layout, but personally I just sit
there and look at the reflection, overlay
and love it.
[ Laughter ]
>>Tor Norbye: So obviously as you're editing
you can kind of keep an eye on this.
And note that as I'm moving the carat around
in the layout you can see the corresponding
views getting selected in the layout preview.
You can see what you're doing.
And likewise I can actually click over here
to navigate around the XML, so it makes it
easy to navigate around and know what the
different parts are.
And just like in Eclipse we have the configuration
chooser up on top here.
You saw me switch devices and you can switch
locales.
This is what we showed in the keynote demo
this morning.
And there's a theme to it, which is now a
dialogue so you can more quickly search for
things.
If I'm looking for dark action bar, for example,
it will find it right there and then I can
click on it to choose it, for example.
One of the really nice things about this XML
preview is that it's tied in with IntelliJ's
XML model, which is really good at fault tolerance.
So one of the nice things is if I, for example,
go and put a typo into this thing right here,
into this switch, what you will see happen
is this widget disappeared because it's no
longer valid, but the rest of the layout actually
completed because it's not starting a fresh
render each time.
It's sort of hey, I have an error node in
the dump.
And this also shows the error panel, which
is showing up in the bottom right here.
So I'm going to create a new layout.
So to do that I can invoke the new menu, new
layout resource file.
So -- oh, and it's locale.
I'm going to switch locale back to English.
So when I'm entering text here, let's say
I enter a button, you can see it's immediately
telling me there are some problems here.
So it's saying you need to insert a width
and a height.
There are also links here, so I can click
on automatically add all missing attributes
and they kind of just appear.
So there are a bunch of error recovery links
right there.
If there's a typo, for example, it will figure
out what you probably meant button, and it
will fix it.
If you use fragments -- let's do it.
I'll add a fragment and we're going to need
sizes again.
So for fragments it's saying, hey, you probably
want to have a class associated with this
fragment, right?
So I can invoke the chooser for that and pick
one.
Countdown fragment, maybe.
And now it's saying that maybe at design time
you want to have a layout because the whole
point of fragments is it's a Java class and
that class can decide based on the time of
day and locale and whatever, logic, whatever
to actually use, a design time you can pick
different ones at different times.
So I will pick a random one and now the layout
is using that fragment.
You can see here in the layout this special
tools attribute, this is where we store metadata.
You can safely ignore those.
In fact, AAPT will also ignore them, so there's
not runtime benefit.
This is how we put stuff in the model, and
we do the same thing in Eclipse for fragments.
One more thing on the device art, we've also
integrated this with the screen shot action,
so in the Android window I don't have a device
connected, but if I did, you could basically
click on the screen shot from your live device,
get a screen shot and then add whatever art
you want.
All right.
So let's switch to the layout editor.
So I'm going to -- in fact, I'll switch over
to this layout right here.
This is a simple form.
So now we're in the layout editor.
And I'll say right away we are not feature
complete here.
Not everything that you had in Eclipse is
ready here.
I will show you the few things where we are
ahead, and that would be grid layout support.
So the grid layout support in our Eclipse
plug-in is very complete and it's much better
here.
As you can see, I can see the rows and columns
here and I can, for example, drag on these
things to re-order them.
If I want to pull in new widgets, here's the
palette and I get the predictable grid and
I can put it between.
If you're doing grid layout editing I would
already use this, but there are some other
areas where we're still working on it.
The good news about this preview, by the way,
is that they have a really good update mechanism.
At least on some platforms it downloads a
small patch file and restarts the IDE so it
takes 30 seconds, and we plan to use this
to have this be a rolling preview.
We talked about every week.
We're publicly committing right now to consider
our update interval.
So that's the layout editor.
Let's see.
The next thing I want to show you is code
editing.
So here's the feature we demoed this morning
in the keynote, and that is the resource folding.
So one of the really cool features in IntelliJ
is they have this folding feature where it
collapses code.
So when you have a static interclass, you
have a run, one line for the override annotation,
another line for the public void run, a couple
more lines for the opening and close breaks,
they will fold that all into a single line.
So we've just used that feature and combined
it with Android's resources to do what you
see here.
This is not the default color that we have
for folding regions, but for the dark theme
the default one was a bit hard to spot for
the keynote with the large screen so we made
it more blue.
But in general you can see here -- let me
click here to open all folds.
So this is what the code really looks like.
So you don't have to know the key binding
I just hit because by default you open a file
and it does one of these get string calls.
We just show the string.
When you hover over it you basically get to
see the real code.
Like this.
And take a look at this last one here.
I'm going to jump into this resource.
And you can see that what this is doing is
it actually has formatting arguments.
All right?
And when I go back and I look at the folded
string, you can see that it's showing the
actual parameters that we have in the code,
sort of in line with the strings.
So it makes it really easy to see what logically
your code is doing.
So now you may wonder, okay, so have you hard
coded this for get string?
We have not.
So if I look for -- let's see -- set text,
for example, what we do is we use an annotation
for this.
So now I'm going to jump into the Android
framework source code.
Hopefully there's nothing proprietary here.
If you look, this is the TextView class.
And there's a new annotation on here and this
is a bit TBD.
We haven't actually integrated this, but I
think there is consensus that this is what
we're going to do.
This is a resource data annotation.
And it's saying, hey, this integer parameter
right here, we expect that to be a resource
in.
So that's the actual thing that the code folding
is using is this method.
So when you call set text, even if you don't
call get string, if you just pass r.string.fu
it will actually do this resolution.
So since we're talking about annotations,
let me show you a few others that we're adding.
If I go to context, you can see not null.
We're also adding nullability annotations,
and IntelliJ can actually show those.
So if I open up the project configuration
for my SDK, there's this annotations setting
where we have basically bundled Android annotations.
So it can basically read annotations from
an external file, not part of the SDK, and
that's how we can actually take these annotations
and associate them with older SDKs and it's
using this on the fly.
So if I now jump down to the bottom of the
file here -- let's see here, for example,
this line is highlighted because it shows
that get current focus, which is an inherited
method from the framework, can return null
and therefore this line could potentially
return -- cause a null pointer exception.
If I jump into the other annotation here,
service name, I'm going to jump to source
for that.
And this is making a local annotation saying
that service name has to be one of these identifiers.
So in fact, if I go back to my Android Studio,
you can see we have another annotation here
saying that you're passing in the right to
set layout direction, but it's the wrong right.
Even though these are both ints and the compiler
is happy to do it for you, we know it's wrong.
And that's because again we have this information
now in this external file that basically records
what constants are allowed for integer parameters.
At that's in this external file that basically
records what constants are allowed for integer
parameters, and in the case of the system
service here, strings.
And we use this not just for semantic analysis.
If I, for example, go in to get system service
and press control space for completion, you
can see it notes the strings there, too.
So especially for integer APIs, it's kind
of nice.
You don't have to know exactly what the strings
are.
At this point, I'm going to jump in and show
you a few other IntelliJ editor features.
So when I was showing you the resources earlier
here, we have references to notification icons
and those are being previewed on the left.
This is the actual size we show them in.
I think we max them out at 14 pixels.
In the keynote we had them bigger to be visible,
but this is what they'll get scaled down to.
So these graphics -- these aren't just for
icons.
If you have a 128 by 128 icon, it will just
be shoved into this editor margin.
And colors are previewed as well.
And if you open up the show documentation
view, I think it's F1.
If not, we have an expert on stage -- F1,
yes.
This is the documentation for this resource.
We show you all the translations right there
in the popup.
And if I do it on an icon, I can see all the
icon versions.
And I think -- yes, it's computing what the
actual pixel sizes are at the different densities.
All right.
So we've also integrated lint.
There was already a lint integration in IntelliJ
but it now does more the inspections.
And lint actually does analysis on both XML,
Java and class files.
And the last part is tricky because one of
the things you'll discover in Android Studio
is it doesn't do background compilation in
the way you're used to.
There's an explicit compile action.
So because of that, lint doesn't have the
class files to look at.
So we've implemented the most important one,
API check, using IntelliJ's own AST APIs.
And so if I look for API check, here's an
example of this.
So if I hover over this, it's telling me that
this API requires 14, and you're current min
SDK is 7, and that's a potential runtime problem.
So what you can do is use an annotation to
basically say you know this method will only
be called when we've already validated that
the platform is at least 14.
The way people typically do that is what you
see on the next slide.
You actually have an SDK check.
And it was very tricky to do this with sort
of flow analysis in the class file but it
was easy with AST.
So this is something we haven't run in Eclipse
or the command line lint yet, but in IntelliJ
it knows not to flag these two lines because
they are inside this version check right there.
We also have a couple of newlin checks.
Is there a talk on the right-to-left text
stuff here at I/O?
If not, at least we have a couple of new lint
checks related to right-to-left and they are
disabled by default but they're a bit experimental,
but if you're trying to target API 17 and
you're doing right-to-left text, you can check
out the lint options.
So in the search box you can just search for
lint.
You'll find all the inspections.
And you can see the ones that don't have a
check box next to them are off by default
and you may want to turn them on.
For the basic Java code analysis in IntelliJ,
there are some off by default that we've gone
and bumped up.
On our team, for the tools, for example, we
make override annotations mandatory.
You can't actually override without setting
the override annotation.
All right.
This part I want to show you a couple of IntelliJ
features that Dmitri didn't get into.
So the first one is scopes.
So here I have a library project, and I can
go ahead and create -- and I'm using action
brochure lock because I'm trying to have an
action bar in an older version of Android.
So I can go ahead and open up the scopes feature.
And I can go ahead and make a new scope, a
new local scope and I'm going to call it action
bar.
And then I can say that I want this to basically
match all of action bar -- I just closed the
dialogue.
Sorry about that.
And now I can basically say that I want to
add everything from -- I don't know, I'm making
a mistake here.
Project.
Okay.
I'm going to choose everything in the action
bar Sherlock and include recursively.
So now we have a new scope.
Now I can go to file colors, and I can basically
add a new color scope for my new scope.
So I'm going to make everything related to
action bar orange.
And now if you look in the project explorer,
everything here is orange.
And if I open these files you can see the
tabs are orange.
And in, in fact, in the recent file dialogue,
things are orange.
So this is really good if you have projects
that you're trying to use and they're in your
work space but you don't want it accidentally
edit them.
You're jumping into resource and you find,
ah, this is actually in the library.
I can't change this.
This feature is really useful for that.
My favorite feature in IntelliJ is open symbol.
So if you are exploring a new API, if you're
not particularly familiar with something in
an API, open symbol lets you jump to a method
name or field name.
So if you're not sure which class to look
in, instead of searching with Google, which
you should do, you can use open symbol here.
So I'm going to use the go to action feature
that Dmitry showed you.
So if you don't know any key binding, basically
you can open this dialogue and just search
for it and it will basically match.
Open symbol.
Okay.
So this is the open symbol action.
And now let's say I want to find out the parent
activity name or something like that.
So I can type parent activity name.
And actually I want to go to this one.
So nav util contains a method called get parent
activity name (indiscernible) in the context.
Another cool feature is injecting languages.
So here I'm showing a method called inject.
And so if you look carefully you can see there's
a green shine to this area.
That's telling me that it knows there's a
sort of different language inside this string.
And if I open up the quick dialogue, it says
this is a regular expression and I can, for
example, open a regular expression tester
and I can type in text to see if it matches.
And so --
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: -- so on the next line, you
can see I'm actually -- I'm going to go on
the third line here.
This looks like XML; right?
I can say inject language and I can pick the
language I know this is.
I'm going to say this is XML.
And now this is going to be treated as XML.
So, in fact, let me make a mistake in the
XML.
So now it's saying, hey, this looks invalid
to me.
It's saying there's no attribute value here;
right?
So it's basically validating my string escaped
as XML.
And I believe this is really useful when you,
for example, are doing database queries.
I think IntelliJ has a database plug-in so
if I were to treat this as SQL, for example,
you can get additional language help that
way.
And I am almost out of time.
The last tip I'll give you is that in a lot
of dialogues, in the IDE, you can just start
typing.
It's not going to tell you you can do this.
It's just something you know.
So my favorite key binding is, other than
alt enter, is control T. Control T is basically
the action to refactor this.
So if you can't remember the key binding for,
you know, renaming or moving or whatever,
just control T, refactor this.
And so here's this dialogue.
Notice that there's numbers at beginning of
these items.
I can just hit the number on the keyboard
to invoke that action but more importantly
I can just start typing.
So if I type change -- actually, that was
a bad word.
Okay.
Constant.
If I try typing C-O-N, you can see it matches.
So it's a very quick way to navigate and this
works in lots of places.
For example, if I want to go create a new
resource folder here, add new resource directory,
if I, for example, want to go and add a language
to my animation folder, let's change that
to layout instead because I like layouts.
Oh, that's the name.
Layouts.
If I add in a new language, you can see we
have region art here.
So if I just start typing Norway, you can
see it's now matching from the whole list
of hundreds of regions down to the region
that I'm trying to add here.
And then I can add my resource photo like
that.
All right.
I'm out of time but there's more stuff, so,
you know, keep looking at our blogs and posts
for additional tips.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: Thanks.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Thank you, Tor.
So one other thing we wanted to do is to cover
more than just, like, regular Android applications.
I mean in the context of Android application.
A lot of your users are going to have more
than one device that have a phone and a tablet.
And if they install your application on their
device they are going to expect those two
installations to be synced together.
So we wanted to add support to really help
you build applications that are connected
like that.
And so I'd like to invite on stage Brad Abrams,
the PM for app engine, to tell you about this
feature.
>>Brad Abrams: Awesome.
So the best Android apps are powered by the
cloud, and customers tell us that google's
cloud platform is really ideal for mobile
back-ends.
And that's why we were very happy to invest
in the Android Studio project.
So what I thought we'd do is actually cloud
connect the stopwatch application that you
saw earlier.
So what we're going to do in just a couple
of minutes is build out a completely synchronized
stopwatch application.
So somebody at the front of the race can have
the stopwatch.
Someone at the end of the race can see exactly
start/stop time of that.
So in order to do that, one stopwatch will
click start.
That will send a rest request up to our server
running in app engine.
That will send a message to GCM.
Beeping is going on.
GCM will send a tickle down to another Android
application, and then that will do a rest
request back up to app engine and get the
actual state.
So let's flip over to the demo and see that,
which is here.
So what I have is the Android Studio, and
I have the exact project that we've been using,
the stopwatch app.
And I thought I'd start exactly where Tor
left off in the keynote today.
Tor did a great job in the keynote, didn't
he?
It was pretty good?
[ Applause ]
>>Brad Abrams: So let's start where he left
off.
We'll come in and say generate back end.
So what this is going to do is -- those values
you can fill in later.
What this is going to do is generate for us
a project, a server project that you can easily
go deploy to app engine that already knows
about this client side code.
So if we look in this server project, there's
a few pieces of code here, and you see we
have a couple of end points.
We have a device end point and a messaging
end point.
The device end point encapsulates all the
plumbing needed to do GCM.
Google Cloud Messaging.
How about of you have actually done GCM before?
And there was probability some drudgery in
getting that to work especially on the server.
So we've taken care of all of that for you
and that's encapsulated in there.
What we want to do now is add our own custom
end point that's going to be exposed as a
custom interface.
So in order to do that, I'm just going to
copy in a stopwatch state class, and this
is a POJO.
This is a plain old Java object.
I've marked it up a little bit, but all it's
storing really is three bits of information:
the device ID, the time stamp, and then whether
or not we're running or not.
So we've got this -- and you can see it's
just got basic accessories on it.
Now what we want to do is take this and we
want to generate a rest interface based on
that POJO.
So what we're going to do is just generate
a cloud end point for that.
And if we flip over into this end point, you
can see we've already got the code for listing
all the entities for doing -- that includes
paging, by the way, in case you have a lot
of these.
You can get the stopwatch state, you can insert
the stopwatch state and whatnot.
So all of that is already done for you.
It stores the data in app engines.
No SQL data store.
But now what we want to do is go and add a
little bit more logic into here, so I'm just
going grab import, and I'm going to do some
of the GCM code.
So what we want to do is when there's an insert
-- so we'll come down here to insert.
Right now when we're inserting, we're just
storing the data in data store.
But what we need to do in addition to that
is send a tickle out over GCM.
So we have some utility code for doing that,
that I'll put in here, and we'll post this
code later so you can take a look at it.
And then we just need to add a little bit
of code to actually do the send.
So right after the -- we persist it.
What we're going to do is get -- enumerate
through all the devices that have registered.
Now, we may have a hundred people with a stopwatch
application wanting to be updated in real
time.
So we enumerate through all of those.
We just check to see if the -- if the one
we've gotten to is the same one that sent
the request, so we don't want to reset ourselves.
So we exclude that one, and then we just send
that tickle.
And then to make this compile, I need to -- throws
I/O exception.
And it's nice to decorate that because actually
we're going to propagate even exceptions and
errors all the way down to the Android app,
as you'll see in a little bit.
So we basically got the server side of our
application done, and you can see it's done
in the same IDE, in the same language, very
easy, seamless to move between that.
Now what we can do is come in and upload this
application to app engine.
Go ahead and deploy it directly from the IDE.
In the interest of time, I've already deployed
that for us a little bit this morning.
So let me bring that up.
What you'll get by default with this project
is a simple test page.
It shows you all the devices that have registered.
In this case, nobody has registered yet.
And then it will let me send a message.
But to explore those end points, if you go
to underscore ah/api/explore, you can actually
explore all the interfaces we just defined.
So you can see there's the rest interface
for C2DM and here's the stopwatch one we just
added.
I can come and interact with this.
I can test authentication.
You see the rest responses and whatnot I get
out of here.
So this is a good way to make sure your server
side logic is working exactly the way you
expect before you start moving to the client.
Okay.
So back in the client, what we need to do
now, we have our rest interface.
We need to be able to call from the client.
So in order to do that I'm going to come back
in here and I'm going to generate a client
library.
And what this is going to do is take the same
discovery document that we -- that powers
that API explorer and use that to generate
strongly tied to Java code that's Android
optimized, mobile aware code, and stick that
in our client project for us.
So to make it very seamless for us to access
this server code.
So now you see it created this new folder.
We're back in the client side of the app.
It created in new folder with these three
end points.
On it.
Now let's take a look at how we go and call
that.
So I've just made a few modifications to the
code to be able to call the end point we defined,
and we'll go ahead and overwrite those.
And the main thing that we just did, we added
some helper class, but the main thing we did
is make sure all the network operations happen
on a background thread.
So either by spinning up a thread or, in our
case, we're using an async worker so that
ensures as I'm doing that network traffic,
the UI is not hanging and freezing and whatnot.
So that's that basic code.
Now, the last bit is I just need to come in
and wire it up.
So when I hit start and stop, the actual methods
get called.
So I've already got a handy dandy added to
my method this send state with end point,
and you can see it's grabbing the current
time.
So I'm actually going to take the current
I'm going to send whether or not this is running
and then my ID.
And this is going to send it up.
And notice I call that in this method startstop.
So whenever I hit start or stop I do a rest
request up to the server.
So I think we've got it basically working.
You guys want to see this thing running live?
Okay.
So let's go.
I think I hit this.
Okay.
So I've got two phones here.
Whoop.
That one can't go yet.
So the first thing I want to show you -- are
we seeing it?
Yeah.
The first thing I want to show you is when
I launch this app, by default the project
that comes with Android Studio, it will give
you this registration screen.
This is your indication that the GCM registration
was successful.
You're able to contact your app engine back-end
and it was able to register this device ID
with GCM.
Obviously when you go to deploy this app,
you can remove this screen.
So we've registered.
Hopefully they're both up.
Let's reset and start this one.
Okay.
Notice when I started this one, the other
one stopped -- started, and when I because
this one, this one pauses at exactly the same
time.
Pretty cool, huh?
[ Applause ]
>>> So let me just switch back here.
And one more slide to leave you with.
We're very excited on the cloud team to support
Android Studio.
As Xav mentioned, we've done the work to make
sure you can do builds of even the server
side stuff outside of Android Studio, so you
can do it in your build tool of choice.
And you can find more information about the
cloud at that URL.
And I'm giving a little bit longer version
of the talk later at this place.
So love to see you there.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Thank you, Brad.
So, you know, it's an Android idea.
We're going to add a lot more features, including
features like the cloud stuff.
That's not where I wanted to go.
So we're still (inaudible) Eclipse and I want
to show you a feature that's new in Eclipse
that about bring to ID.
You saw during the keynote we translation
on the play console, and I want to show you
that now.
So here -- so this is my account, you know,
and I have an app.
It's called sample app.
And I can create a new translation.
So I already have some French translation
that are ready to go but I'm going to create
a new version.
I'll call that test.
My original translation is in English.
Continue.
All right.
And here I can use the plug-in.
If you have a complex project, you're going
to have a lot of strings and you probably
don't want to go them and upload them manually
so generally in the plug-in you can say use
plug-in and then you're told what to do, which
is useful.
And then you can to Eclipse where we have
this new plug-in.
It's not part of the bundle, the bundle that
we have with ADT and Eclipse.
It's available.
If you go to developer.android.com you have
the instruction right next to the ADT instruction
to install it.
And from here you can very easily -- I think
from here translation manager, you can just
do request translation.
So I already -- there you go.
So I already logged in with my same account,
and it discovered that I had my, you know,
test project that is waiting in my browser.
And so I can just click next, and then it
knows all the strings that I have so you can
go and look and make sure those are the strings
that you want and then you just upload them.
In that case here, just a single string, but
if you had a lot of string file, it would
just upload all of them, which is really convenient.
And when you finish, you go back into the
console here, you click continue, and then
you say, well, I want to translate them in
German, for instance.
You click okay.
And then you choose your translation.
And then you choose some translator.
And then you click confirm, and then you get,
you know, a week later, your translation.
And then of course we want same thing; right?
Because the format you get back from the translator
may not be exactly the format that we want.
So here we go and easily click download, and
here I have some translations here that are
ready, and so I click next.
There they are.
I click download, and on the left here on
the values, I have my -- you show here which
string you just got.
And you got your string translated directly.
So the whole work flow is directly integrated
into the IDE.
We'll have (indiscernible) Studio, of course.
It's available now.
I think you have to go and sign up for the
pilot to be able to do that.
All right.
And this is, you know, the end.
We have a couple of -- well -- no.
So we are taking questions.
You know, so feedback again.
(Indiscernible).
We have a mailing list, (indiscernible) @Google
groups, and then we'd love feedback on Android
Studio.
All right.
[ Applause ]
>>> The translation is a nice feature.
A question is what if you translated it once
and then you added a couple strings or changed
a couple?
Does is it know to just ask for translating
what changed?
>>Xavier Ducrohet: I think it deals with that.
There is a talk on Friday at 12:00 p.m. that
will talk a lot more about that, and you should
go and check it out.
They will probably have the answer.
But I think the (indiscernible) already been
translated and they only translate the new
things.
>>> I'm looking forward to your weekly updates.
I want to get a clarification on the direction
between Eclipse and the Studio and kind of
validate where we're going with the two IDs.
>>Tor Norbye: We suspected that question would
come up.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yes, we are going to keep
supporting Eclipse.
You know, that's something that we won't be
able to do in Eclipse because it has, you
know, the language framework is not as good,
or as extensible.
So it's harder for us to plug into it.
But we are going to keep supporting Eclipse.
Right now we're focusing a lot on studio because
we have to bring a lot of the features from
ADT into studio but we're going to keep supporting
both.
At some point we're going to integrate Gradle
directly inside ADT also so you have a single
build and (indiscernible) to be able to build
with that.
>>> One of the things -- First of all, thank
you for using IntelliJ.
It's a great IDE.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yes.
>>> One of the things that I missed from Eclipse
is merge manifest.
Do you know when that's going to be available
for --
>>Tor Norbye: It's a feature of the new build
system.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yes, the new build system
merged the manifest so you don't have to do
anything.
We still support the old builder in IntelliJ
in case you have an older IntelliJ project
that you are using so you can open it and
use it, but the default behavior is to use
the new build system, and the new build system
deals with merging the manifest.
>>> Is that available now?
I already use IntelliJ.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yes, it is available now.
>>> So just on --
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yeah, if you get Studio,
you'll have automatically create a new project
and you'll see the new build system and it
does manifest merging.
>>Tor Norbye: In the new -- in Android Studio,
you can't create -- in the Android Studio
version, not with plug-in in IntelliJ, you
can't create old style.
You can only create Gradle-based projects
because we're really trying to get that part
working beautifully.
>>> Translation question.
My apps are all translated by volunteer users.
I'd love to see crowd sourcing in your framework.
Anything on that?
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Again, session at 12:00
on Friday, the people who deal with that will
give you a big LMO and they can answer that
question.
>>> Thanks for the switch to IntelliJ.
>>Tor Norbye: Last question.
>>> That's really appreciated.
I'll have to get used to Gradle, I guess,
because I'm using Maven to do all the builds.
I have a question about compiling with multiple
APK loops.
You mentioned action by Sherlock before.
That's commonly used and it is not uncommon
to use it with Holo Everywhere and Holo Everywhere
Preference.
Maybe with your own APK lib as well.
So in some of my projects, I'm building with
four APK loops all at once.
At the moment that takes a long time because
you have to run ADTs through all of them.
Where are you progressing on that?
>>Xavier Ducrohet: So we have better support
for that.
I think it's a lot dependent on text merging
to be able to help with that, but we have
a new feature to merge resources that's more
incremental, so that will be faster.
(Indiscernible), we're improving that a lot.
It may not be just there yet, but we're improving
it a lot.
Also, one thing is because of Gradle, you
won't necessarily need to have all those projects
open in Eclipse before you have to.
You have (indiscernible) open, so here you
can just focus on one module, and that makes
things faster anyway.
>>Tor Norbye: So we're unfortunately out of
time, but we're going to be out there.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: So we're going to be at
the office hours and we'll be there as long
as people have questions.
So, you know, just come and talk to us.
>>Tor Norbye: And that's right now.
We're going there right now.
All right.
Thank you.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]